the protests are drawing new attention
to the death of a black man in Tacoma
Washington caught on camera three months
ago Manuel Ellis died from oxygen
deprivation
after police physically restrained him
the 33 year old man was hurt on a police
scanner saying I can't breathe the
medical examiner ruled his death was a
homicide
Ellis's family wants the officers to be
arrested police say he threw an officer
to the ground Carter Evans reports on
the investigation in the video showing
the confrontation a frightening scene is
witness video captures Manuel Ellis's
fatal encounter with police two white
officers wrestled Ellis to the ground
and held in their he was later declared
dead at the scene as I watched that
video I became even more enraged
overnight Tacoma mayor Victoria Woodards
called for all the officers involved to
be fired while I am mayor I am still
black I am still treated as an
african-american woman I am still looked
at as an african-american woman and my
life could be taken and today it was so
like sweet and loving and he would
always give me like the biggest hugs CBS
News spoke to Alice's sister mone
alongside Sarah McDowell who filmed the
incident for what he wasn't even doing
anything
officers say they got into a struggle
with Ellis after he repeatedly struck
their patrol car and assaulted one of
them but McDowell disputes that saying
Ellis was just walking down the street
when the officer has gone out of their
car and body slammed in it just looks
like you can't breathe there's no heads
on knees or no cutting off of
circulation none of that Pierce County
detective ed Troyer says the officers
involved were placed on leave after the
incident but defended their actions
throughout the process he had trouble
breathing and he told people I can't
breathe they put him on the side call
for medical aid James final who read
since Manuel Ellis's family is now
calling for an independent investigation
by the state of Washington the
law-enforcement agencies that have been
investigating this and utterly failed
this family and this community for CBS
this morning I'm Carter Evans